it's turning into a sobering year for
the fintech industry after mega funding
rounds and new unicorns in 2021 private
fintech companies are now scrambling to
cut costs and stretch out the funds they
have to avoid raising more money at a
lower valuation with publicly traded
fintech companies down more than 50
percent since november venture
capitalists are pumping the brakes on
funding for the sector startups that
said it's still been quite the ride
fueled in part by the pandemic
accelerated shift to more shopping and
banking done online in february 2020
just before covet 19 hit the average
valuation of america's 10 biggest
private fintech companies was 9 billion
and the cutoff to make the list was 3.7
billion dollars for this year's list
those numbers have more than tripled
here are the 10 biggest fintech
companies in america for 2022. at number
10 is good leap worth 12 billion dollars
the california-based company makes it
easier for users to make green home
upgrades contractors and vendors use
goodleaps app to get customer project
loans approved for solar panel
installation and 20 other categories of
sustainable improvements at number nine
is brex also worth 12 billion dollars
the company provides fdic insured
corporate cash management accounts and
corporate credit cards with no account
fees travel rewards and built-in expense
tracking its tens of thousands of
customers include class classpass airbnb
and carta
openc takes number 8 on the list valued
at 13.3 billion dollars a big winner of
2021's nft craze open c is a
peer-to-peer platform where users can
create trade buy and sell nfts the
company keeps a 2.5 percent cut of each
sale and has processed about 3 billion
dollars in nft transactions every month
openc maintains dominance in the nft
space but key competitors like coinbase
are trying to close the gap plaid is at
number 7 with 13.4 billion dollars the
company helps fintech apps like venmo
connect to customer bank accounts to
make payments and deposits easier
earlier this year platt acquired
identity verification and know your
customer or kyc compliance provider
cognito for 250 million dollars at
number six is blockchain.com worth 14
billion
the british crypto exchange is the
world's most popular cryptocurrency
wallet which allows users to manage
their private keys for several
currencies it has expanded to the us and
can now serve customers in 35 states
number five is ripple worth 15 billion
dollars the company facilitates
international payments and remittances
through blockchain technology and its
dedicated cryptocurrency xrp ripple has
more than 300 institutional clients
including standard chartered and
moneygram the sec is suing ripple for
alleged illegal securities offerings
through the sale of xrp but the
company's ceo says he may consider going
public once the lawsuit is settled
chime comes in at number four with a
valuation of 25 billion dollars the
largest digital bank in the u.s chime
rose in popularity by providing free
checking accounts with no overdraft fees
and offering cash advances to its
customers the company was preparing to
go public earlier this year but delayed
the ipo due to the rocky market at
number three is ftx one of the largest
crypto exchanges in the world the
bahamas based company is worth 32
billion dollars after a 500 million
dollar raise in january eager to become
a household name it has been spending
hundreds of millions of dollars on
marketing and acquiring celebrity brand
ambassadors number two is klarna with a
valuation of 46 billion dollars a
pioneer of the buy now pay later model
klarna banked on customers moving away
from credit cards but still wanting to
pay over time the company makes most of
its revenue by charging retail partners
for affiliated marketing and payment
services clarner made the number two
spot at the time of this list
publication however its valuation has
since plummeted to 6.7 billion dollars
still the company has raised 800 million
dollars in fresh funding and finally at
the number one spot on the list is
stripe with a 95 billion dollar
valuation the company helps big and
small businesses process online payments
take out loans and automatically
calculate and collect sales tax the
company remains the most valuable
american private fintech and is the
world's fourth most valuable private
company following tick tock owner bite
dance spacex and chinese fast fashion
seller sheen